we can't like cut this in half yo real
talk i'm from brooklyn i carry a blade
like i can take this
y'all think i'm playing but nobody's
just right
on this right here
hey everybody it's nicole russell from
last dragon pizza
welcome to peace awards on first week
feast pizza is one of america's most
regional dishes
it's not just about new york it's not
just about chicago for decades
detroit has been home to some of the
best pizza on the planet detroit pizza
was really put on the map
by sean randazzo he passed away last
year and this episode is dedicated to
him
cooked in a steel tray a pizza from the
d is chewy
saucy and surrounded by crisp
caramelized cheese
and i can't think of anyone better
suited for detroit styles showdown
than my friend cliff skywalker
[Applause]
what up doe i'm cliff skywalker i'm the
owner and operator of cliff's pizza in
pontiac michigan
i'm always going to be one to champion
how great detroit style pizza is it has
a special place in my heart i'm not
gonna lie to you the origins of it
coming from blue steel pans that were
used for cars
it just is a reflection of not only
the hard-working people of the city but
the innovation so what i'll be doing
today is a garlic shrimp pizza
it's just going to be a great bite with
every piece that you have
so today i'm making our scarparillo
detroit style piece of sauces chicken
lemon and rosemary delicious
today's judges are full tv icon adam
richmond
and rayna scully the host of first we
feast gochee gay
these two have eaten all over the world
so i think they're gonna like my
non-traditional take on a detroit style
pie
cliff it's game on so get ready for the
showdown
[Music]
clint skywalker's in the building thank
you so much for being here
i'm so excited to have you like i said
from jump it's an honor being here you
have no idea this is so dope
all right so let's go look what you got
going on so i'm gonna make the garlic
shrimp pizza
it's the go-to for a lot of people on
the menu that haven't had my pizza for
the first time and then it becomes their
favorite so
what makes a detroit pizza a detroit
pizza
first off this pan this is like a blue
steel a detroit style pizza pan
the dough goes all the way out to the
edge the cheese goes all the way out to
the edge and you get that like crispy
really really dark brown edge yeah that
acts as the crust
more so than the actual bread oh my god
so let's go
yeah let's get let's get straight to it
all right um we have our tomato sauce
usually for detroit style pizza they do
a sauce on top but i kind of want the
shrimp to be the star of the show
that's right so we're going to build
this like a standard
let's do it if that's okay oh it's
perfect with me
we don't do rules on first we feast next
up
is the cheeseburger okay wisconsin brick
this is
oh my god sometimes when you get this
scent to you and it gets unpacked it
looks like a key
like like this don't snart the cheese
listen
[Laughter]
i like to hit the edge the pizza with
the brick cheese and now i'm just going
to lay
this cube mozzarella just a little
mozzarella now we're just going to
sprinkle the roasted garlic on because
you can't have a garlic shrimp pizza
without
garlic shrimp pizza you know a lot of
people say oh you're not supposed to put
shrimp on pizza
listen i don't see what the problem is
what did you say about first week feast
there's no rules here
so guess what we're making shrimp pizza
exactly
well i have to tell you you got me a
little nervous now don't do that
listen i know that at any moment i'm
gonna feel
like joe pesci when he walked into the
room with goodfellas like i know i know
that's coming and i'm gonna look around
and be like
ah and i know you're about to hit me wow
so i'm kind of looking for it this is
pretty much set and ready to go okay
so we're gonna go ahead and uh throw
this in the oven at around 10 minutes
i'm gonna pull it out real quick add
some shrimp that's been marinated
in some sriracha throw it right back in
the shrimp should cook perfectly as the
pizza continues okay
oh yeah the cheese is bubbling i can see
so i like to give a little flip
oh like oh oh
that looks so good you showing off right
now
okay i gotta get a little piece of
shrimp in mine i'm putting my shrimp to
the front
oh go ahead get a little asmr
come on now come on i heard that from
here
the crust is so pillowy and soft that's
what i like about detroit pizza and you
nailed that
thank you and then i love the crispy
edges and sriracha is actually
hitting me right now but guess who's
going for more me i feel you
mmm you're giving me a run for my money
for sure i'm trying to listen you know
what i'm saying i know you got the home
field advantage but i'ma try to do my
thing out here in these new york streets
i really love your pizza now i want to
show you what i'm going to do ready i
respect it i'm with it
cliff that shrimp sriracha pizza was
incredible
thank you and you know i'm not from the
deep i'm from new york
true and true but today i'm going to try
to give you a run for your money
my favorite italian dish is scarpariello
and it's like this sausage chicken
rosemary
lemon dish and every time i go to a
restaurant an italian restaurant
i automatically say oh i want scar per
yellow what i did last night is i took
some chicken
thighs let it stew and then i you know
added some butter and just deglazed the
pan
some white wine you know what i'm saying
a little something i was gonna put some
hennessy for you but i said you know
what let me keep it classy
some spicy hot italian sausage rosemary
butter and lemons you ready for this
no so first things first i'm gonna
choose this beautiful aged
cheese i'm packing the cheese all around
the corner so it can get nice
and crispy right there what i'm gonna do
now is add some shredded mozzarella so
i'm gonna go cheese first
okay i'm gonna add my sausage and
chicken scar prairie yellow mixture
and then i'm just gonna take a little
sauce i'm just doing some stripes across
okay so the last thing i'm gonna add is
some roasted
red peppers i think it rounds out the
flavor
so nicely we're gonna throw this in the
oven for about 10 minutes and i don't
know i'm excited for you to try
this okay
it's out whoo it is
sizzling it's like a frying pizza
i think i deep fried my detroit this
might be a little bad form i gotta take
a picture of this though
that's crazy are you ready to try this
born ready if he rolls his eyes i know
it's good
what do you think you like it he always
does that
when cliff does the eye roll you know
you gucci
listen
in the words of birdie mac i'm in
trouble
trouble you get that pillowiness in the
middle
the sauce perfect complement to the
cheese that's scarf hair yellow
that's a whole different set of problems
that i unfortunately have to deal with
um we're on camera so i'm trying to be
modest as soon as you cut
this is going to look like a murder
scene well cliff your pizza was
outstanding thank you and you know i did
my best and i feel like my dish is
pretty amazing too
but we got to go to the judges table we
got adam richmond here
food tv legend and we got reyna scully
our first we fees family let's do it you
know what i'm saying
win or lose i'm just proud of you i'm
proud of you
let's go
adam raina thank you so much for joining
us today oh thank you so much for having
us
all you had to save his pizza today it's
all about detroit style pizza
cliff and i we both made some great
pieces for you today
and quick you're gonna go first fair
enough all right so what you have in
front of you
is a garlic shrimp pizza the shrimp was
marinated in sriracha overnight little
bit of a roasted garlic with it
topped it with basil and a little honey
sriracha something i call the elixir
so have that enjoy
the elixir i love it i have to say one
thing i love
is just aesthetically you know because
you do eat with your eyes a little bit
yeah this is just beautiful looking all
right shall we we
shall
[Music]
um wow oh the honey is that the elixir
a little bit wow i gotta get my favorite
part of that lacie yeah yeah hold on
right there that's how you know what to
say watch this asmr
fill me from here up because i'm having
reactions down below
i'm trying to make sure my microphone
gets too crunchy
i think it sort of shows like a very
chef knowledgeable hand
in that new par bake and then add the
shrimp so the shrimp are perfect
i love that little spicy kick it's so
good it works its way perfectly yeah
that's sweet heat that honey
is crazy it works so well thank you so
much
and short i'm moving into cliff's house
hey man we got a spare bedroom man
what's up
i gotta pronounce you cliff and adam
[Music]
well this is certainly a tough act to
follow
but this is my pizza and the topping is
scar par yellow have you guys ever had
scarfare yellow do i look like a man
who's not acquainted with an italian
restaurant
this is not the my physique
italian dish right the dough is a very
high water dough
i also added semolina to the dough so it
gives it a little bit more texture
kind of maybe behaves like a corn meal
for the butter yeah but not as harsh
it's going
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh oh hmm
oh my god i am a huge italian food fan
it's hitting the italian palette there's
kind of a kick
with some of the sausage we need that
note that's a little bit different it
can't just be the same over and over
it's so good
and this is the other thing too that you
can see how the fermentation really
worked beautifully
creating those wonderful air pockets in
the dough you wanted to
recreate scarpari yellow and you brought
that oh thank you
i was really hoping one of y'all will
[ __ ] up
[Music]
okay adam okay rayna you showed us both
so much love but now is the moment of
truth
who will go home with the pizza trophy
we can't like cut this in half yo real
talk i'm from brooklyn i carry a blade
like actually
i think i'm playing but
just sort nobody work on this right here
i'm gonna be honest i think that there's
like a millimeter difference
in one element i i think oh my god
oh my god yeah yeah absolutely okay that
was
the deciding factor i think it's just
that little like michael phelps
fingertip touching 0.007 seconds ahead
three two one nicole
oh well
thank you and honestly it was like
the flavor of the semolina in the crust
and it wasn't a matter of better it was
just different
the fact that we can identify it the
fact that we could both bite into it and
we know what it is that's big
real talk i personally feel i could flip
a coin
and wherever it landed like easily
declare either one the winner they are
both
fantastically successful fantastically
delicious pizzas
[Music]
i want to just say thank you so much
claire
for everything thank you so much
and i really wanted to represent the d
with you and i just so appreciate you
coming through
and join us next week on peace awards
[Music]
you